anyway here with reaction Fox News
contributor former Speaker of the House
New King Richard uh great to have you Mr
Speaker
so
I know I speak for a lot of Americans I
watched the wef I saw what happened in
Davos uh I see the amount of money we
pay for the U.N the wef the who
we paid the vast majority of money for
the Paris climate Accords China and
India are classified as developing
nations and they pay a fraction of what
the U.S pays my question is why does the
U.S continue to pay the bulk of monies
for many organizations International
that don't seem to like us very much
well first of all a lot of the liberal
Elites who favor paying the money don't
like us very much either
so if you were to ask people like John
Kerry he's much closer to the
international organization's disdained
the United States than he is to people
who think America is the most important
country and that Americans ought to be
taken care of I thought it was
symbolically perfect that at the time
when East Palestine Ohio really needed
attention uh President Biden was in Kiev
giving away more money and proposing
that the United States create a welfare
state for ukrainians that we would pay
for I mean this is the kind of policy
that is madness I'm for defeating Putin
I'm for helping the ukrainians
militarily but I am against the idea
that we should pour endless cash out
with no notion of what victory would be
and with no notion of responsibility so
uh I think if you want to get to a
balanced budget one of the places you
started is pretty simple Chinese economy
is almost the size of the American
economy
let's match the Chinese contributions
they give 198 million we'll give 198 but
that saves us about a billion here a
billion there not big money but if you
can save four or five ten billion
dollars by not giving it away
it is a step towards a balanced budget
which is what I'm one of our major goals
should be so the who we've given
hundreds of millions of taxpayer dollars
to and Joe Biden would agree if they go
forward with this agreement he would
agree to give over 20 of whatever
pandemic
whatever pandemic materials we have be
it vaccines uh uh be it gloves be it
Mass be whatever it happens to be at the
time we give 20 percent to the world and
take it away from the American people
shouldn't we take care of Americans
first with American money before we
pledge to share it with the rest of the
world we'll share but we have to take
care of Americans first why is that not
a priority
well because I think if you were a
liberal Democrat uh you inherently
believe that the United States is not a
good country you know Gene Kirkpatrick
used to Ambassador Kirkpatrick you gave
a great speech once describing the blame
America First Democrats well what's
happened is they've now become the
weekend America First Democrats if you
look at everything the Biden
Administration is doing from the borders
to releasing criminals uh to releasing
terrorists to uh giving money to Iran uh
again and again what's the number one
pattern you weaken America weaken
American energy increase the importance
of Russian and Saudi energy and
Venezuela
I think you have to understand that from
the standpoint of the left the United
States is a bad country and so the left
really does believe that you shouldn't
stand for the national anthem you
probably shouldn't say the Pledge of
Allegiance you certain certainly
shouldn't teach American history
accurately because their vision is of a
World in which the world submerges us
that's part of why they love an open
border I mean if they can get another 20
30 40 million illegal immigrants they'd
be thrilled yeah they would think that's
terrific and every time we assimilate
and get people to become Americans it
just it terrifies the left Asian
Americans now work very hard want to get
ahead and guess what liberal School
boards discriminate against Asian
Americans because they do too well again
this is the same pattern and what you've
pointed out about International
organizations I think would be good for
the Congressional Republicans to go
through inch by inch everything we're
spending outside the U.S and decide is
that really more important than a
balanced budget is it really worth
burdening our children with that debt
and if not quit spending it uh Mr
Speaker great to have you thank you for
being with us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else